welcome to this dw business special
looking at the international assault on
russia's economy i'm rob watts it's
great to have you with us now the west's
sanctions against russia over its
invasion of ukraine are starting to bite
and hard moscow is warning inflation
could hit 23 percent this year and the
economy is expected to sink into
recession now for ordinary russians the
international assault on their country's
finances has become plain to see the
clearest sign of american and european
sanctions can be found in shopping
centers where the storefronts of many
western brands are now closed mcdonald's
is completely pulling out of russia
having opened its first restaurant in
moscow in 1990 just before the fall of
the iron curtain and others such as
pepsi starbucks and ikea have also
closed their businesses with no plans to
return in the foreseeable future
meanwhile prices especially for food
have risen enormously
but to help us better understand the
impact of sanctions on russia and where
its economy is going let's meet our two
guests joining me in the studio is aaron
tilton who spent a long time as dw's
correspondent in moscow it's great to
have you with us we'll be talking a lot
about i suppose the the impact of the
situation on russians themselves right
also joining us on the line uh not in
the actual room with us is uh janice
kluger he's a senior associate at the
german institute for international and
security affairs it's great to have you
with us janis thanks a lot we'll be
speaking to you very shortly but i do
just want to start by talking to aaron
tilton who's with me here in the studio
aaron how has life changed for people in
russia
since the invasion of ukraine um well
when it comes to the financial situation
the economic situation the sanctions
have really increased insecurity at a
very insecure time for the russian
people um especially you know the um
the ruble crisis that we saw right at
the beginning with its price bottoming
out and its value against the dollar
that caused a lot of panic i think among
many of the russians i um i talked to
and the people i talked to regularly you
know we saw a brief run in the bank
people were trying to get their money
out of the bank because of course it
evoked memories of the two other major
financial crises that the russians have
lived through in the 90s and it did seem
like there was
a lot of panic going on you saw a lot of
people panic buying you know
goods manufactured in the west and while
that's kind of tapered off a little bit
it does seem that there's a lot of just
basic more baseline anxiety are they
noticing changes in their economy oh
well definitely definitely i mean prices
of food you're saying yourself have shot
up dramatically um a lot of high-tech
and consumer electronics are no longer
available or the price is shot and up
massively at the same time while there
aren't a lot of the layoffs that were
actually predicted by some western
economists there's a lot more job
insecurity on the market there are a lot
of companies that are dealing with
supply chains that involve the west or
maybe sourcing their labor from foreign
companies but they no longer have access
to that and that means a lot of small
and medium-sized businesses are kind of
on shaky footing we've already heard
about some layoffs and some closures as
well and the longer these sanctions
continue to bite and um affect the
economy you know the more that unsecure
that insecurity is going to be growing
as time goes on well let's actually have
a look at the impact that it has been
having on the russian economy we can
actually just look at the various ways
in which this has been assessed you know
in terms of pure numbers russia has
already taken a big hit since the start
of its invasion into ukraine gross
domestic product in february was you
know running along nicely but it took a
hit in march as it it was as and is
expected to fall by eight and a half
percent for 2022 as a whole so that's
according to the imf let's uh bring in
janice kluger on this and just speak to
him about you know the the true impact
that we are seeing there i mean that
8.5
fall in gdp this year that's a very
different story to what was expected for
russia this year isn't it
that's true of course i mean what was
expected actually was a recovery from
from the covet crisis so strong growth
which we actually saw in the first
months of the year
especially against the back of high
energy prices so this actually was
supposed to be a great year for the
russian economy and it has turned into
the opposite and
i think that it's important to know that
8.5 is just one estimate and we are
dealing with a lot of uncertainty here
and there are other also i mean very
solid estimates uh for russia's gdp
contraction this year which reached to
15 of gdp so um 8.5 percent might even
be a modest outcome or that's a benign
outcome in comparison to the other
figures which are out there
yeah and when we talk about figures we
should also talk about inflation in
russia which is also something that's
forecast to to reach extreme levels
really this year let's have a quick look
at the forecast for inflation in russia
so price rises are a concern in so many
parts of the world aren't they at the
moment but russia's finance ministry
says inflation could rise as high as 23
this year compare that with the eurozone
where inflation is expected to top out
at around seven percent and you can see
it's there's something really very
different going on in russia janice i'm
just going to stay with you on this one
and just ask me what is it that's behind
that rise in prices that we're seeing
there why is it so different to everyone
else
there are different factors i mean at
first we had the very weak ruble which
made imports more expensive so this is
actually a very
common driver of inflation in russia
where the rupa goes usually inflation
goes
and but now we have a different
situation with the ruble which is a
separate story
but at the moment if you look at
inflation it is more driven by just the
scarcity the sheer scarcity of goods
many things are just not available
anymore or just you know becoming
scars and
i think that when we look at inflation
we also have to understand that that
this number it doesn't mean the same
anymore like before the crisis because
as you said earlier the problem so the
problem for russians is that many goods
are not even available anymore so
inflation is about prices but when you
cannot travel to europe or if you cannot
get certain goods if you cannot go to
mcdonald's then uh you know the price of
this service of this good becomes
meaningless and it's just about the
price of what remains and the living
standards are you know are being hit by
you know things becoming unavailable uh
facebook or other social media platforms
i mean even even smartphones i mean if
you cannot buy these things the prices
become meaningless so this inflation is
just part of the story
let's turn to taran tilton on that
actually and just talk about the fact
that things are becoming scarce and
they're also seeing these these brands
leaving the high street
are russians blaming anyone for this are
they blaming their government's actions
well i don't know that they're
necessarily blaming the government's
actions you have to remember vladimir
putin and his government have crafted
this narrative for the better part over
the last two decades of this um kind of
anti-russian front assaulting the
russian federation and these sanctions
really kind of play into that narrative
that has become kind of the bedrock of
the russian identity right now so
basically what putin and his supporters
are saying is that there is this bright
coalition or this very wide coalition
of powers that want to see a weak
russian state and they say that these
sanctions are an attempt to [ __ ]
economically um the russian people and
the russian states so this really kind
of plays into that narrative and while i
do think at least privately a lot of
people may actually be blaming the
government russia is not really a
country where you have a safe space a
safe space to view voice some of those
oppositional viewpoints so at least
publicly you're not seeing a lot of
debate about that you're not seeing a
lot of blame for these economic sections
being laid at the feet of vladimir putin
instead it's usually blamed on this
anti-russian prejudice that supposedly
exists in a large part of the western
world let's actually take an opportunity
to hear from the russian government on
this because from the outside the
russian economy does appear to be
feeling the strain but what's the view
being put forward from the kremlin karen
linner well let's hear from the
country's president vladimir putin
russia is confidently coping with
external challenges thanks to the
responsible economic policy of recent
years
as well as the decisions to strengthen
economic sovereignty and food security
our companies are gradually occupying
the niches in the domestic market that
have been left empty after the departure
of unscrupulous companies
against the backdrop of a record
positive foreign trade balance the
exchange rate of the national currency
the ruble is also strengthening this
year it demonstrates probably the best
dynamics among all the currencies of the
world
well let's actually take a look at how
the ruble has fared in recent months and
compare that with what vladimir putin
was just saying so this graph that
you're about to see it begins the day
before russia invaded ukraine and then
you can see how the ruble crashed losing
almost half of its value against the
dollar in the immediate aftermath of the
invasion but since then it steadily
climbed back to above its value before
the war began let's talk to janis kluger
about this janis
and it looks there like the ruble is
doing pretty well actually is that
telling all the story
no it's not telling the story because
we have to consider that the ruble the
the exchange rate it doesn't mean the
same thing that it meant before the
crisis the central bank the russian
central bank has changed the rules of
the game and this has this means now
that the the exchange rate is based on
completely different factors than before
right now what the ruble tells us is on
the one hand that russia is still
exporting a lot which is of course
actually a good sign for russia but at
the same time it tells us that russia is
importing very little and this is a very
bad sign i mean the lack of imports
the lack of access to to foreign goods
and technologies this is what's really
hurting the russian economy so if you
look a bit closer at what drives you
know the appreciation of the ruble
exchange rate we see that it contains
both something bad and something good
for the russian economy but it doesn't
you know although it is you know
perceived in russia as a as basically an
indicator of the health of the economy
it doesn't do that anymore it's the you
know the ruble exchange it doesn't mean
the same thing that it meant before the
crisis
so does that mean we should continue to
see it staying at the sort of level that
is a sort of healthy level if you
compare it with you know how it was
before or should we expect the weak
they're able to weaken once again
this is a very good question and um it's
still a bit uncertain it depends on if
russia's imports can in fact recover so
um the cheap ruble and the the very um
strong ruble actually makes it cheaper
for russian importers to you know buy
goods for example in china or india you
know if they manage to get the logistics
going and if they you know manage to
increase imports again later in the year
then this might lead to weakening of the
ruby because then also there is a more
more stronger demand for foreign
exchange in russia which is not there at
the moment it also depends on how russia
russia's exports you know are faring
further down the line in this year it
depends on the question if there will be
in
an oil import embargo by the european
union which would be hit the russian to
russian exports it depends on if russia
will find new customers also for its oil
deliveries some place else in the world
and so these are sort of the factors
that will shape the you know the fate of
the ruble i personally expect it to you
know continue to appreciate a bit more
because the problem of imports will
persist longer and then either the
central bank will change the rules of
the game again and allow for a bit more
um flexibility you know it will allow
allow the ruble to weaken a bit more by
um by by weakening the capital controls
a little bit that it has put in place
and then later on in the year if imports
actually get going then it will weaken
again
yeah i mean this is all about how russia
interacts with the rest of the world
isn't it and as the war continues and
the western allies consider their next
step there is one big elephant in the
room and it's russian oil uh
correspondent teddy ostrow has more on
g7 negotiations over an eu oil embargo
and the us proposals of of tariffs on
russian oil all of which is designed to
hit moscow in his coffers
are also seeing some fault lines we are
seeing some cracks in this alliance
specifically with regard to oil and
whether or not the european union can
actually ban it without a major struggle
um possibly even a recession and the
question is how the united states has
tried to help um janet yellen the
treasury secretary has suggested tariffs
but to the grumblings of some european
diplomats and we have to remember that
you know russia is being hit from all
sides the european union and the united
states have hit russia financially with
sanctions and we're watching as the
united states makes moves to try to push
the russia into default by not allowing
it to pay its bond debt but again this
debt that russia has been to everyone's
surprise been able to service up until
now potentially um dwarfs the revenues
that it gets in from its oil exports so
the real question here for the g7 is
whether or not they can solve this
question of oil and we will see whether
they can
teddy astro on the new york stock
exchange for us there i'm just going to
turn one last time to aaron tilton aaron
we're hearing about you know the
situation in the west at the moment how
is that viewed by by people in in russia
do they have very little sympathy for
the trouble that this is causing for the
country they're actually applying these
sanctions
um well to be absolutely honest um i
haven't heard a lot of chatter about
that you do see a lot of framing coming
out of the kremlin saying of course this
these sanctions and these uh the specter
of an oil embargo that it's only going
to backfire they're constantly trying to
spin it around and saying that these
actions taken against russia are
actually going to be harming western
economies and they often actually like
to point to germany as this particular
example of that because germany is more
dependent on russian gas than almost any
other country in the eu right now so um
if anything i think they they kind of
view it as a self-made problem and um
definitely there are forces in and
around the kremlin hoping to use that to
their advantage moving forward
especially as the months start getting
colder and a russian gasket starts
getting more expensive
and just a last line to uh janis kluger
janis you actually wrote a couple of
years ago an article that was all about
your prediction for the next 10 years of
the russian economy that was written in
2020
i imagine that has changed somewhat now
absolutely i mean
although actually i developed several
different scenarios there was not a
single one which anticipated uh the kind
of economic destruction that or
transformation or prehistoric as uh as
the central bank head of the central
bank calls it
the transformation russia is going to go
through it's it's really unprecedented
and and it will be painful and yeah it
was just impossible
to predict that this is happening now
and um and the outcome is still very
uncertain
okay well thank you janice klueger for
taking the time to speak to us that is
all we've got time for on this business
special looking at the impact of
sanctions on the russian economy thanks
a lot to my guest aaron tilton here in
the studio with me and janice kluger if
you have got enjoyed what you've seen
here then please do remember to hit the
like and subscribe button as we say here
on youtube and also why not check out
some of our other stuff on the dw news
youtube channel from me and the team
it's goodbye and until next time take
care
you